when I first heard eyes closed I didn't
know what you had written about I didn't
know it was about this friend of yours
Jamal he was like you're everything he
believed in you and no one else did
that's the impression I got we sort of
met uh late teens and I was a struggling
singer-songwriter and he had this uh
online YouTube platform I met my manager
through that I met the guy that signed
me to the record label through that uh
and it just started this this wave but
at the same time like I was living with
him he'd become my best friend and we
were having this sort of Rise together
and um I just remember waking up in the
morning and getting a call and just
being like he's dead and it's you know
I'd been speaking to him like four hours
before that I know that's the thing that
everyone says when people pass away like
oh I just spoke to them but I was in he
was my best mate so I was in constant
conversation with him and I just didn't
believe it for ages the guy was 31 years
old you didn't expect him to die do you
feel like oh why wasn't he more
responsible why didn't he take care of
himself he's such a great guy he's a
great human being there's many more
layers to that man I think there's you
know there's many I don't want to go
into it but there's there's more layers
to it than just what the media have
reported basically it's um you know it's
a shame that all of that stuff came out
in
the Press I've I find I find press with
people of note that have passed away
very disrespectful how they I had
another friend that passed away and they
released his um biopsy afterwards it's
just I just find that weird like who
reads that who who reads that apart from
the family and goes why is this out
there I just like why do you need to put
that out there why can't it just be this
guy passed away and let's all be sad
like I don't understand why you have to
talk about the way it just yeah that
that made me really angry when that came
out and it's just not nice for his
family and friends when someone's taken
away like that it's even more of a shock
because he's young he's vital he's
healthy he's your best friend
and then he's gone and so at what point
can you even write a song about him in
the month between him passing away and
the funeral you know we lived in West
London both of us and we used to go to
all these different places
and I would go to the places in that
month to remember him and think that he
was going to walk in and obviously he
didn't and yeah that's what the
inspiration behind the song basically
was yeah it's a real personal song this
is about Jamal your friend and Beautiful
song called eyes closed thank you
[Music]
I know it's a bad idea but how can I
help myself be inside for most this year
and I thought a few drinks they might
help it's been a while my dear dealing
with the cards like that I'm still
holding back these tears when my friends
are somewhere else I pictured this year
a little bit different when it is
February I step in the bar it hit me so
hard how can it be this heavy every song
reminds me of gone and I feel the alarm
form in my throat cause I'm here alone
just dancing with my eyes closed
cause everywhere I look I still see you
time is moving so slow
and I don't know what else that I can do
so I keep dancing with mine
[Music]
oh I keep dancing with my delusion is
here again and I think you'll come home
soon the word brings me right back in
then it's only me that's in this room I
guess I could just pretend the colors
are more than blue I lost more than my
friend I can't help but missing you a
picture this month a little bit
different no one is ever ready and when
it unfolds you're getting a hole how can
it be this heavy Everything Changes
nothing's the same except the truth is
now you're gone life just goes on so I'm
dancing with my eyes closed
cause everywhere look I still see
time is moving so slow
and I don't know what else that I can do
so I keep dancing with my eyes
closed
oh I keep dancing with my eyes
[Music]
closed
oh I keep dancing with my shutting the
bar they're cleaning the floor everyone
is already home but I'm on my own
still dancing with my eyes closed cause
everywhere I look I still see you time
is moving so slow
and I don't know what else that I can do
so I keep dancing with my eyes
oh I keep dancing with my eyes
[Music]
oh I keep dancing with my
Jesus said that's a beautiful song thank
you man I mean just a beautiful song
What a tribute to Jamal